gracias por estar con nosotros en
reporteros comenzamos en lo que va de
este 2021 al menos 970 personas han
perdido la vida en la ruta migratoria
del mediterráneo' según la organización
internacional para las migraciones sin
embargo para las ong que rescatan a
decenas de personas en esta ruta la
cifra dista mucho de la realidad
diferentes embarcaciones intentan llegar
a europa pero nunca son encontradas un
grupo de organizaciones humanitarias
tratan de actuar pero su actividad se ve
cada vez más obstaculizada por los
bloqueos aleatorios de sus barcos de
rescate en los puertos del sur de europa
por la pandemia y por la falta de
asistencia de las autoridades aunque
sean competentes durante las operaciones
de salvamento
[Música]
estamos a bordo del ocean by king
la organización humanitaria ss
mediterránea uno de los pocos barcos de
rescate que siguen presentes en el
mediterráneo central su tripulación está
formada en su totalidad por
profesionales del rescate rescatistas
médicos enfermeros y especialistas en
logística el pasado mes de abril tras
una larga búsqueda frente a las costas
libias lograron rescatar a 236 personas
en peligro
los sobrevivientes dan su testimonio
si la unión europea piensa que libia se
lleva a los migrantes para ponernos en
centros de canción no es cierto no hay
centros de detención son prisiones son
pisos
unos días antes los equipos de ese oeste
mediterráneo llegaron demasiado tarde
después del naufragio de un bote
inflable en medio de una tormenta
durante horas en lausanne banking pidió
la intervención de las autoridades
competentes pero fue en vano alrededor
de 130 personas murieron ese día
realmente espero que el naufragio cambie
las cosas en términos de coordinación y
transmisión de información cuando se da
una alerta de riley
de distrés
mediterráneo central 21 de abril
hello sun bike y responde a un mensaje
de alan forme una asociación ciudadana
que retransmite las llamadas de socorro
en el mar mediterráneo
a más de 220 kilómetros de distancia
frente a la costa de libia
unas 130 personas se encuentran en
dificultades a bordo de un bote inflable
la noche anterior la embarcación había
salido de la costa libia con otro bote
que fue interceptado por los
guardacostas libios
llama a los guardacostas libios y
pregúntale si los dos casos están
cerrados
y se han interceptado ambos o sólo uno
luisa al ver a coordinadora de búsqueda
y rescate de ese mediterráneo intenta
ponerse en contacto con las autoridades
competentes porque si es solamente uno
de los dos estamos seguros de que
podemos tratar de salvar al otro si no
están muertos
según el derecho marítimo le corresponde
a libia coordinar ayudar a realizar los
rescates en la zona donde nos
encontramos
buenos días este es el traductor del
ocean by king
hablo hablo árabe
disculpas
lo que me gustaría saber la pregunta que
tengo es el avión de reconocimiento vio
el caso 182
dyn
ok ok
no son
ok
simplemente colgó sin decir salam
aleikum
ok
el interceptaron un bote de interés y
estoy seguro es el caso 183 es una
locura que no hayan visto al otro
pues estaban tan cerca
ok terminamos gracias ok entonces
continuó así gracias
ante la falta de cooperación de los
libios el lausanne banking cambia de
rumbo para dirigirse a la embarcación en
peligro pero todavía está más de 10
horas de distancia
[Música]
sí
ah
[Música]
a todos los barcos a los kings ante la
posición del mail
[Música]
reconoció la voz es frontex
de cerio transmitieron a mayday mayday y
esa es la posición del bote en peligro
aquí me transmitieron a los vidrios no
es la hora radio mayday mayday barco en
peligro esta posición eso es todo
[Música]
el mayday es un mensaje de socorro
enviado en caso de peligro inminente de
muerte según el derecho marítimo
internacional quienes lo envían deben
identificarse en este caso frontex la
agencia europea de vigilancia de
fronteras transmitió el mensaje de forma
anónima más de 9 horas después de que
alan form le informará a las autoridades
todavía quedan más de 150 kilómetros
para llegar a la posición indicada por
frontex
el viento aumenta las olas son cada vez
más altas
[Música]
se avecina una tormenta
buenas noches llamo desde el ocean by
king podría hablar con el oficial de
guardia por favor
ante la falta de reacción de libia tras
el mayday luisa al ver acude al centro
de coordinación de salvamento marítimo
de roma para transmitir la posición
embarcación en peligro en la
jurisdicción italiana
buenas noches este es el auto
a las 19 15 recibimos un mail del canal
16 de vhf dando la posición 33 26 en el
2013 56
estamos lejos de esta posición que sería
posible enviar un mensaje por satélite a
todos los barcos de la zona
sí sí
la parca en el barca de peligro es una
embarcación para expediciones
los 26 pero se mide por la radio vhf
yo siento
vale gracias por su tiempo adiós
me dijo no es nuestra área recibimos
información y gracias es nuestro trabajo
tras el mayday tres buques mercantes
desviaron inmediatamente su rumbo para
intentar rescatar a la embarcación en
peligro
hoy
[Música]
espontáneamente y sin ayuda de las
autoridades organizan una búsqueda
metódica de la zona
[Música]
en medio de la tormenta el ocean banking
parte en una carrera contra el tiempo
para llegar a ellos esa noche las olas
alcanzan los seis metros de altura una
sola ola sería suficiente para romper
cualquier bote inflable
[Música]
en la madrugada hello son biking llega
finalmente al lugar y se une a la
búsqueda
[Música]
y
copia
luisa al ver a intenta comunicarse con
osprey el avión de frontex para recibir
asistencia aérea
buenos días que están coordinando la
búsqueda
[Música]
el microscopio
expresiva en algo pueden compartir la
información
y nuestro barco está bien equipado
[Música]
tenemos médicos e incluso un amor que si
encontramos cuerpos y
flores
así que estamos bien equipados para la
búsqueda y el rescate
i
h
[Música]
gracias a que el lección biking en el
canal 16 fuera
nuestra iglesia
a pesar de sus promesas frontex no le
dio noticias directamente a lausanne
biking al mediodía se confirma lo peor
el buque mercante myrow se localiza tres
cuerpos sin vida
unos minutos después el avión de frontex
les dio la posición exacta de los restos
del naufragio a los demás barcos de la
zona
cuando los equipos de ese mediterráneo
llegaron al lugar de los hechos sólo se
veían los trotadores del bote
durante la tormenta el fondo del barco
se dio ante la violencia de las olas
además
esa noche se ahogaron unas 130 personas
[Música]
no encontramos un sobreviviente era
obvio que no había ninguno después del
naufragio
es una cuestión de tiempo siempre
es la primera vez que alarcón de un
mensaje a las autoridades
a la buena mañana del día anterior
el doctor había mucho tiempo para
saludar el morning out day
day before
range of time to
cerca
ante la violencia de la escena los
equipos de ss mediterráneo están
conmocionados
bajo la fuerza de la tormenta los
cuerpos quedaron a la deriva a lo largo
de varios kilómetros
durante todo el día el ocean by king
esperó instrucciones de los guardacostas
libios encargados de recogerlos
besteiro encina anti nos quedamos en el
lugar hasta la noche y esperamos al
barco patrullero libio que nunca llegó
y decidí continuar patrullando para
poder salvar más calling
desgraciadamente para la gente de ese
barco en peligro no había nada más que
pudiéramos hacer y por the world ends
botines tres bebés nacen no puedo hacer
algo que los demás y no puedo salvar más
vidas y me quedo en esta suerte de more
life y si hay otra llamada de socorro
puedo prestar ayuda no hay otra solución
no hay otra autoridad sino seguir los
tres no haber no haber way there is no
haber authority detener
cinco días después de la 'u' fragio el
único barco de rescate presente en el
mediterráneo central el ocean by king
responde a un nuevo mensaje de socorro
[Música]
los equipos se preparan para socorrer a
dos botes implantes
en la operación participan socorristas
médicos enfermeras y personal de
logística
[Música]
o mejor dicho
al acercarse las embarcaciones en
peligro los tres botes salvavidas del
ocean by king son puestos en el mar
[Música]
esta vez el mar está apacible pero cada
bote lleva más de 100 personas
[Música]
uno de ellos está a punto de ceder bajo
su peso deben moverse con rapidez y
garantizar la seguridad de todos
[Música]
una vez se reparten los chalecos
salvavidas el traslado de los náufragos
-alusión biking puede comenzar
bueno
[Música]
la operación de rescate durará dos horas
236 personas subirán al barco entre
ellas siete mujeres
119 menores no acompañados
y yaya un bebé de 18 meses
[Música]
por fin todos están a salvo
para tripulación lo registra uno por uno
luego reciben atención psicológica y
médica
como en cada rescate de los botes son
destruidos sistemáticamente para que no
puedan ser reutilizados las frágiles
cámaras de aire como únicas boyas dan
testimonio de los riesgos que corren los
candidatos al exilio así como de la
falta de escrúpulos de los traficantes
de personas
al amanecer del día siguiente los
equipos se preparan para llevar a cabo
otro rescate espontáneamente los
sobrevivientes del día anterior se
ofrecen para organizar la recepción
encubierta
pero justo cuando el ocean by king
estaba a punto de intervenir
guardacostas libios le ordenaron que
cambiara su rumbo
[Música]
el ocean by king debe acatar ya que se
encuentra en la zona de búsqueda y
rescate de libia a bordo de los barcos
patrulleros financiados por la unión
europea los guardacostas libios llegan a
toda velocidad pueden hacer volcar las
embarcaciones en dificultades bajo la
mirada de los sobrevivientes del día
anterior en pocos minutos interceptan y
amontonan en su pequeño bote patrullero
a casi 200 personas
el ocean by king observa la escena con
impotencia solo imán conoce bien los
métodos del ejército libio ha
sobrevivido a dos interceptaciones el
barco libio vino e hizo que el sóller se
volcará
que estaba gritando mamá mamá voy a
morir
los libios vinieron
[Música]
empezaron en vez de salvarlos mientras
estábamos viviendo empezaron a tomar
fotos
fotos primero tomaron fotos
y entonces enviaron un pequeño bote a la
gente mientras que nos insultaban y nos
golpean
otros sobrevivientes dan testimonio de
un sistema bien organizado en el que los
traficantes de personas se mueren de
acuerdo con las autoridades para
extorsionar a los migrantes organizar
los botes y luego interceptar los
su objetivo es hacer que quienes quieren
llegar a europa
paguen varias veces la travesía
nigeria no nos cuenta y
hacen el lanzamiento ellos mismos vienen
tras una
lo atrapan y lo llevan de vuelta a libia
eso significa que quieren una doble
ganancia
no paga el viaje luego lo traen de
vuelta supuestamente en la policía todos
lo sabemos pero no tenemos el derecho
porque no estamos seguros no podemos
contarlo todo
a bordo del ocean by king los
sobrevivientes por fin reciben atención
médica
esta vez no hubo heridos graves pero sin
muchas quemaduras causadas por el
combustible mezclado con el agua del mar
del sol yo embargo carcome la piel
a bordo la vida finalmente retoma su
curso y se establece una rutina los días
están marcados por la distribución de té
y como consecuencia de la pandemia por
las tomas periódicas de temperatura y la
distribución de mascarillas
rescatistas y sobrevivientes comparten
las tareas diarias
[Música]
el pequeño ya ya que parece haber
olvidado la angustia de la travesía se
convirtió en el consentido del equipo
otros 119 jóvenes no acompañados
hicieron la travesía musa de 15 años se
fue de guinea conakry en febrero decidí
viajar desde que era pequeño y la
situación estaba en la escuela era
inteligente siempre era el primero de la
clase pero ese no era mi objetivo mi
objetivo soy inteligente sé que si tus
padres no tienen los medios en un punto
que estudies
habrá problemas de dinero
por eso me fui de guinea conakry
pacari 14 años llegó a libia procedente
de costa de marfil en enero
trabajamos trabajamos no nos dan comida
nos golpean todos los días todos los
días
los libios no son hombres son muy malos
muy violentos
ya no nos dan comida ya nos golpean todo
el tiempo todo el tiempo solo imán
quiere denunciar esta violencia que se
ha convertido en algo habitual está
fuertemente teñida de racismo
en libia el negro es una mercancía como
animales estamos acostumbrados a la
violencia cuando somos negros siempre
somos inferiores para los árabes
siempre somos inferiores siempre nos
sentimos minimizados
si la unión europea piensa que libia se
lleva a los inmigrantes para ponerlos en
centros de detención
no es cierto no hay centros de detención
son prisiones son prisiones
es un comercio de seres humanos basados
en negros
varias veces al día el ocean by king
solicita a las autoridades italianas
llegar a su puerto seguro hay que
armarse de paciencia para pasar el
tiempo algunos de los sobrevivientes
juegan a las cartas otros mide la
distancia hasta el país de sus sueños
[Música]
otros aprenden las fases del italiano
para prepararse para su nueva vida
finalmente hay alivio cinco días después
del rescate al barco se le asigna un
puerto de desembarco
[Aplausos]
más
a
ah
más
el primero de mayo el ocean by king
llega al puerto de augusta en sicilia
aquí es donde desembarcarán los 236
sobrevivientes
las aduanas italianas están listas y las
autoridades sanitarias suben a bordo
para realizar pruebas kobe a todos los
ocupantes del barco
[Música]
luego uno por uno los sobrevivientes
desembarcan
[Música]
porque aquí
los menores no acompañados son separados
de las mujeres que los cuidan desde
libia y son enviados a hogares de
acogida
los adultos se dividen en los que
resultan positivos por ccoo y 19 y los
que no
[Música]
tras varias horas de espera finalmente
embarcar en los ferrys de cuarentena
italianos donde pasarán varias semanas
mientras los sobrevivientes comienzan su
incierto viaje en europa la misión del
ocean by king llega a su fin
dentro de unas semanas volverá a zarpar
para salvar más vidas desde el inicio de
sus operaciones en febrero de 2016 ss
méditerranée ha rescatado a 33 mil 519
personas a su vez las cifras oficiales
indican que más de 20 mil personas han
muerto en el mediterráneo' una cifra que
probablemente esté lejos de la realidad
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros el documental recuerda que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web las
24 punto com para ver esta emisión y
también las anteriores hasta la próxima
semana
[Música]